hey everyone it's stephanie wong cloud
developer advocate and today i have
again
google fellow eric brewer here we have
been doing a series of videos we hope
that you have enjoyed them so far but
eric we are both so excited for this one
because we are gathering our questions
from the community right i am looking
forward to this it is true all right so
we have both put out a prompt for
questions and this is meant for anything
that you've been curious about around
eric's work over the last decade any
advice that you've had for our next
generation of developers especially in
the kubernetes space
so first off the first question that
we've gathered is can we make use of
kubernetes in the edge mainly the
raspberry api devices where security can
be a big challenge
well people are definitely using
kubernetes at the edge mostly in the
telco space in the retail space
uh certainly some well-known large
customers actually run kubernetes
clusters in each of their big stores
so it's definitely in use of the edge
today
uh it also runs on raspberry pi so
that's not
per se new either although that is a
more constrained way to run for sure
i would say the implicit question though
that it's uh less secure i would say is
neither true nor false would say
kubernetes hasn't certainly an option to
be quite secure secure as other things
based on say traditional vms
however it really comes down to the
whole stack so what is the security of
your hardware for example
do you have any uh root of trust in that
hardware google service that we but at
our data centers actually have a
hidden key deep in size we actually know
we're running on a real server we know
that the bios is trusted we know that
the os is trusted so we build up a
trusted stack and run on that that's
historically harder to do with the edge
but it's still a good goal right right
increasingly important as well uh
especially given the work that you are
doing around bringing security to this
kubernetes and open source era
uh now what about data so we have
another question about what kubernetes
would look like
in the i'm assuming data analytics space
currently data applications are
relatively cloud specific
certainly kubernetes started with less
focus on data and more focus on services
especially stateless services those are
the easiest to do for lots of reasons
and that goes again back to the 90s as a
basic principle
but everyone is building data services
on kubernetes now of many flavors and
that it is certainly possible now to do
a good job of that but i think the
question sounds like it's more about how
do we kind of have the same kind of
revolution for data that containers
brought to computing or services brought
to computing and that is a is a great
question and it's not easily answered
and
but i think the service is a good
framing for that meaning that
when i talk about data it's not just the
actual data it's probably what are the
you know the methods to use an
object-oriented paradigm or the apis
around that data because if i have an
api view in my data that i also start to
talk about policy who can read it who
can write it access control kinds of
things maybe i can force other policies
like data locality this data needs to
stay in europe for example so i do think
we need a bit better packaging of the
data itself and the wrapper around it
and i would say this group's exploring
that
but i would say that's still to be
right and this is related but i think
there's also an increasing need for more
processing power to do things like
machine learning data analytics high
performance computing so
what is the future for co-processors in
the kubernetes space like using gpus
tpus etc co-processors in general are an
important part of any computing future
we're at the end of moore's law in the
sense that general purpose computing is
not getting as fast as it used to per
year the rate of change is slower which
is too bad for all of us
one of the few ways you can make up for
that is to have more domain specific
hardware that's what a tpu is for
tensorflow that's what a gpu is both for
graphics and is used for ai
so accelerators are here to stay and in
fact you can use both cpus and gpus from
kubernetes there's nothing wrong with
that i would say in fact there's a new
offering in kubernetes on gke where you
can actually
uh subdivide a gpu into smaller pieces
so it's actually easier to use a small
amount particularly for inference or to
use a large amount if you want to do
training but absolutely that is part of
the core feature of kubernetes yeah and
it's been incredible to see the
extension and the usage of kubernetes in
the machine learning space
especially with open source platforms
like uh kubeflow and what we've built
into
vertex ai so it's it's really exciting
and i'm looking forward to seeing where
we start to implement those things
now this question is a common question
that i think we get but talking about
on-premise private clouds versus public
clouds but to you what is the right
balance between open public cloud and
private closed sovereign clouds for
companies
that's a very tricky question which many
countries are worried about
so the short answer is
you'd be better off with a open public
cloud pretty much all the time if you
could use one because it will have
better cost efficiency will have a
higher rate of innovation
it can do more things over time
however
that means you must not only trust your
cloud provider but you also have to
trust the government that runs the
country in which your cloud provider is
based
which for most clouds is the us so if
you're a country that is worried about
the us government you may decide at
least some of your workloads that's too
risky
and you really want them running in your
own country that's where the word
sovereign comes from in these contexts
now the good news is something that's
based on open source like kubernetes is
amenable to running well in private
clouds that's a big part of anthos which
is something i've worked on also for
both hybrid and multi-cloud
so you'll see us talking about sovereign
in terms of our general open cloud
extension because at least that means
you can use kubernetes on gke and for
some reason you need to exit
for whatever reason you can run
kubernetes on-prem and at least your
workloads will be movable now is it
trivial to do that no but it doesn't
have to be triple it just has to be
possible
absolutely it's a tough space but
it's going to continue to evolve over
time as our geopolitical climate changes
so it's a lot to think about now
now many many great tech including
kubernetes and bakery as you know came
from internal google technology that
we've decided to externalize so i think
the community is curious but what is the
next big thing that we are hoping to or
we think we might externalize
well i think it just happened but people
didn't realize it which is
google has great internal solutions for
supply chain security
uh we've written papers on it uh vcid is
an internal name i don't know what it
stands for but basically it's a set of
invariants about how our software is
built such that we can prove things
about it before it operates for example
we can prove internally that every
piece of code is in our repo and that
multiple people have looked at that code
to make sure that it's safe and those
are strong savings to be able to make
and we can make them internally now to
externalize that it's kind of like
externalizing bigtable we didn't
actually release the actual bigtable
code if we had no one could have used it
because it had a lot of dependencies on
internal google stuff
so we wrote a paper people wrote
versions of it externally leading to
eight space and other things that's one
model equivalent here is salsa
which is now part of open ssf where it's
this is a framework for how to think
about supply chain but the good news is
it's based on what we actually have been
doing internally for for i think at
least 10 years and what we already know
works in production so it's like big
table it's proven in production we
actually externalize it with the
community because it's again
that we'd have buy-in on how it works it
needs to be
done an appropriate way for open source
which is not that easy hence need some
discussion that process is going on now
people are absolutely welcome to
contribute it'll also be a big part of
the executive order as we move towards
secure supply chains in general for the
nation
exactly exactly it can't be done in a
vacuum
and uh we are inviting the community to
help us bring these things to the
broader industry as a whole
so that is a great note to end on eric i
know that you have shared your time with
us over the span of this video series so
i just want to thank you so much for
sharing your knowledge and your
experience my pleasure and great to be
involved with in this way thank you so
much for everybody else we hope that you
enjoyed this video series let us know if
you want more like this and if you do
have thoughts comments questions
concerns jokes
check us out on social reach out to us
on twitter we'll include our handles
here thank you so much everyone
[Music]